qué va a suceder a partir de este
momento bueno se espera también entonces
el pronunciamiento de la corte
constitucional para que emita un
dictamen si esta aplicación de la muerte
Cruzada procede si esto no procede por
parte de la corte constitucional esta
decisión volverá a la asamblea nacional
y el presidente de la república estará
en una posición muy difícil de poder
gobernar ante un parlamento que se
mantiene en contra que estaba realizando
inclusive un juicio político en contra
del primer mandatario pero ya el
ministro de gobierno Henry pucalón
habría anunciado la facultad que tiene
el presidente de la república para
convocar a esta figura constitucional y
que no tenía ningún impedimento para